welcome to CBS this morning we begin
with this US officials are blaming Iran
for an attack on Saudi Arabia but
President Trump does seem to be lowering
any expectations of a US military
response the president told supporters
in New Mexico last night not to panic
about oil supplies after the
unprecedented attack on Saudi oil
facilities nor he said he is weighing
his options one day after tweeting that
the u.s. is in his words locked and
loaded
sources tell CBS News many of the
projectiles involved in the weekend
attack were fired from Iranian territory
they say at least one missile passed
through airspace over Kuwait a US ally
Ouisa Jiang is at the White House visa
how close is the president to making a
decision
good morning Anthony president Trump is
not committing to any timeframe but he
announced a team led by Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo will head to Saudi
Arabia and the u.s. is talking to its
neighbors in the region as he decides
how to respond and as Gael just pointed
out yesterday we were right here talking
about the president using tough language
military action but now he is pumping
the brakes today we got a lot of oil we
got a lot of gas president Trump
downplayed concerns about oil and gas
prices while campaigning in New Mexico
you know a few years ago if we had a
problem like you saw two days ago in the
Middle East we would have been in a
panic although not if I were your
president we never panicked earlier in
the day the president stopped short of
blaming Iran for the attacks on to Saudi
oil plants but indicated it was likely
Iran we want to find definitively who
did this certainly it would look the
most like it was Iran the president
secretaries of state and defense have
both blamed Tehran in tweets and CBS
News has learned US Intel officials
believe Iran was behind the attack a
Saudi Arabian military spokesman said
the weapons are Iranian but was unclear
where the attack originated as far as a
response everything seems to be on the
table on the one hand the president
practice restraint
I don't want war with anybody I'm
somebody that would like
to have work on the other keeping the
possibility of using military action
open even suggesting a lethal
retaliatory strike would be a
proportional response I'm not looking to
get into new conflict but sometimes you
have to this is a very significant
attack former CIA acting director
Michael Morell says the u.s. may have
little choice it's not only Iran it's
that's under pressure here but they can
put pressure back on us we have to deter
them on Capitol Hill House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi has requested a briefing for all
House members on the bombings with
Democrats urging caution on next steps I
don't think we need to be the protector
Saudi Arabia United Nations inspectors
have traveled to Saudi Arabia already to
investigate what the US works on
declassifying information to share
meanwhile Iran continues to deny
involvement Tony today its supreme
leader said there will be no talks with
the US on any level which is hanging at
the White House we should thank you very
much